bro do you know many people watching
right now we're scared to ask out the
person that they were most attracted to
and thus missed out on the opportunity
to marrying the person that they most
were into that's life
you don't ask you to get you got your
prospective
[Music]
I'm not
so we're on the way to this fireside
chat with Ken Aletta the advertising
week here in New York which means there
are thousands of events for the ad world
going on throughout the week a bunch of
our leaders are doing a bunch of events
and I'm doing one as well to give your
macro context blog we have a new person
filming won't you say hello hello what's
your name
Josiah and just how you excited beer yes
good because I'm just sighs excited
I'm only here Monday the Jets lost to
the Jags yesterday so I'm super pissed
Congrats Jacksonville
I'm only here today I'm in London the
rest of the week so I'm trying to cram
an entire week into a day so I'll be
rolling until midnight tonight now I'm
running to do this quick event and so
that's where I'm at at this point yes
this event will probably be the meat of
this episode because you haven't been
able to film quite a bit yet because so
many internal meetings just operating
the business one of the vulnerabilities
of the vlog is I talk about being the
entrepreneur CEO operator of my
companies but you don't get to see it
because so much of it a sense of you
know information you're getting a
first-hand look day one of how much
can't be filmed but
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
amazing amazing watch your stuff thank
you I don't know how you have the time
to do all this videos do it
it's just prioritizing to me you know
especially you know being in the
creative field I think being a
practitioner of the craft that you're
trying to get people to understand is
powerful you know I didn't grow up in it
you definitely did it in the ad we're
like we couldn't do the same things
Apple did or Nike did as individuals but
now with distribution being commoditized
for changing I think it's important for
me to understand the context of creating
and distributing content with an agenda
no different than what I would require
want target or and so I just I
prioritize it is the real answer I think
people still view it as secondary or
nice to have and I believe that for a
lot of the people here for all of us the
vulnerability becomes when you get so
far away from the reality of the end
consumer we're sitting in an ivory tower
so I grew up in using marketing and
advertising to build a family business
for me the way I view it is unless I'm
putting in the time to actually create
distribute write copy edit think then
I'm vulnerable to being the thing that I
think is most vulnerable in the ad world
now which is a lack of understanding of
what's actually being consumed by the
end consumer so it takes a lot of time
but to me there's three meetings I'm
probably having every weekday that are
less important that I think they are
that if I can allocate that to content
creation and distribution and
understanding of the end consumers
thoughts will
better in the other 19 meetings I'm in
that are meaningful with a point of view
a strategy and understanding 15-20 years
ago and also advertising told you what
you're gonna wear yes yeah where you go
to vacation yeah what are you gonna
drive yes
2018 all these movements going all this
spiritual going on it's changed now the
advertisers are reacting yes
the you as you know as a key guy in the
middle of all this yes our great guy to
talk to thank you you know I'll be
honest with you I think if you could go
back to the 1960s or 80s that if a
company an advertiser or a brand that
was advertising was doing it right they
also were reacting aka listening I think
the difference today is that you I him
and everybody watching well they can
make the content that we listen to so
it's more visual but if you go back to
just do it or priceless or where's the
beef or the Jolly Green Giant the
strategy and insights that led to the
creative were imperative they get in
focus groups they did it a different way
but I would always say the best talking
aka advertising was always on the back
of the best listening I just think that
all of us can see the way brands are
listening now because it's in all our
faces and everybody's producing talk to
me about how Hollywood athletes all
different walks of life together and
their voices now of being heard where
the advertisers are listening as you saw
with the chase spot with Serina in the
US Open I think the biggest difference
today then let's say the Babe Ruth or
Mickey Mantle or Joe Montana days is
humans can now celebrities or any human
can go direct to the consumer and they
don't need an editor in the middle
they don't need Walter Cronkite in the
middle they don't need ESPN in the
middle and what that's doing is changing
the distribution and message dynamics in
a way we've never seen so yes whether
you're you know Beyonce or Serena or
or a politician or an actress on a hit
Netflix show you've got leverage now
that we've never seen before because of
Instagram Facebook YouTube and podcast
going directly to the consumer not
having a middle man filter you stop you
or package you in the way that they want
[Music]
Podcast
videos
I need to kind of take some of these
chances I mean have a great gig I'm in a
good place but I'm also trying to
and to me I'm sure you must have picked
up on this wife's resonating it blows me
away how young I think you and I are I
think and I think that is confusing to
you and I normally yeah because we
working industry with but that's I think
it's important and it makes me so happy
because I'm I means a lot to me like I
just don't think I don't know we've got
50 [ __ ] more years of it I don't know
why people think it's over for tail end
and I get it I know why because we were
putting in work for a long time right
but that makes me happy that you are
one of the fastest growing at platforms
is owned by Amazon yes you see them in
the future destroying everybody's space
if the government doesn't stop Amazon
it's disproportionately the biggest
company in the world they are the the
level of respect I have for the merit of
the skill sets of their executions and
how Bezos has run that company pissed me
off because I'm like [ __ ] like I always
rely on well I still have 40 years to
execute to do my thing man they have I
mean it's unbelievable to me how good of
a company that is and and here's why and
it is absolutely why I think any level
of success I've had in my career it's
been on a very similar principle they're
they're outrageously Pro their customer
Amazon's winning because you love it
prime is like oxygen like everybody buys
everything on it and so and then they'll
ever enter they left they layer and
they're taming on top of it don't even
want to get into like the fact that
sawdust is one of my favorite business
concepts which is like selling a
byproduct of what you do which they've
done better than anybody with Amazon
services they built all that
infrastructure for themselves then they
sold it to the world
I mean that company has just done so
much right it's uncomfortable you can
make an argument that no one has better
data than they have because they have a
unlike search which is where you're
interested in or or Facebook which is
where you and your friends are talking
about they have actually would you
purchase yeah I mean they're there how
will they how do you see them using an
advertised it easy when that data goes
to the web and and they and they share
sell or leverage that data what's
amazing about Google is its intent to
buy right what a lot of very educated
people here know is that Google Ads
are extremely strong even against
Facebook if you're talking about sales
intent in a short term where Facebook is
crazy and why I've been surprised the ad
world has an embrace that more is
building brand than top of funnel people
misunderstand Facebook in our industry
they think of it as more of a direct
sumer strength place it is Facebook is
absolutely the platform that has has
replaced television for the ambitions we
have for television which is creating
above the funnel top brand awareness
what Amazon has is the cleanest data you
could see about buying because it's not
even intent like I want to buy scissors
on a Google search is really good data
if you sell scissors and then you put
ads in front them but actual data that
you bought scissors that's that really
matters and so when you think about
their ambitions and I think people are
very naive I don't think people
understand what happens next I think
you're about so for example actually
this is really wild because I saw the
branding I'm convinced that target is in
deep [ __ ] and that they have no place in
the world of retail and that either
Facebook or Amazon will buy them right
and so like I don't think people realize
the retail wars that are in front well
because what Facebook has to understand
because I think Cheryl mark are super
smart and what Google has to understand
is that Amazon's retail leverage is
unbelievably important to the
advertising world that we all live in
and I think I think I would be stunned
if target isn't sold to Facebook Amazon
Google or maybe even Apple I would just
be stunned because it's a it's a pillar
that the rest of them are vulnerable to
to Amazon in its data and execution and
leverage
[Music]
like I'm so flattered that people
appreciate my work I mean I don't think
people are like I will never too bad I
take for granted that somebody wants to
take a selfie with me that is like so
flattering this like you know even
hearing you say you're Gary Vee like
fooling I'm aware of what's going on
they will never be my soul I'll never be
Gary Vee in my soul I'll always be
Gennady Vaynerchuk who's like six years
old who like can't speak like you know
like there is no I'm not capable of
going there I can't get over that hump
and become a caricature of myself or
somebody I'm not
I just wasn't parented that way I just
wasn't brought up that way my
experiences don't give me the ability to
sell out that's it you know would you
say like I wanna be a something you say
with parents healing would you say a lot
of that has to do with like just the
fact that you're able to do that like
granted like being that great both
grateful yeah to be in this position
it's also the things I put on a pedestal
I think it's cooler for you to tell your
cousin in seven weeks that Gary Vee is a
real dude then I think it is of me being
so cool that I have no time for nobody
that's what I think is cooler
I think being nice and a good dude is
cooler than being too busy for somebody
some people don't some people think cool
is being like unavailable and like
bigger than them like so it's it's my
own ideology of what is like winning
look like you know
oh my god nine years ago i retweeted
something and you did like a random act
of kindness and sit flowers to my house
okay which was like a fun like you
should have just sent flowers was this
one I said you should send flowers not
just on this on Valentine's Day or
birthday with you to Vegas I'm like oh
yeah yeah he sent me flowers already yes
I just got beam lit for the UN project I
told you about pretty much you know so
it's gonna be massively so happy God
willing it's gonna be huge
I hope so thank you guys I'll sock you
later how many how many sneakers did you
buy to have this five-minute thing right
that's [ __ ] ludicrous like the fact
that you paid 3500 bucks for all this
awareness is laughable like so if I'm
hackable
everything's hackable like this is meta
in itself like for two seconds I was
promoting this opportunity and you were
the smart [ __ ] to take advantage of it
dude it's not a lot of [ __ ] money for
the exposure you're right it's a lot of
money I don't [ __ ] on 3,500 and most
people don't have it but the fact that
you can repost the [ __ ] sneakers on
eBay and get 60 of them back like like
if you're and that's the point bro if
you're a [ __ ] hustler you can do
anything right like you could spend all
day like you could like this is your
dream
you could spend [ __ ] 11 hours a day 2
hours a day 1 hour day DMing 150
different creators and being like yo
I'll give you a tenth of a point of my
company we talked about this or you know
like whatever it is but like it's just
hacking moments right
it's just hacking you mean the Facebook
group person line the one that everybody
who's watching this should join huh tell
everybody now I'm gonna do a [ __ ]
commercial tell everybody here how
ridiculously awesome first online
Facebook room is for the community I'm
good I'm good always wins man just
[ __ ] does okay what else gonna answer
it for you and this kind of like your
last minute your last lick I mean I
think the growth strategy is twofold one
is that you go and hack the community of
Instagram to I think you take this video
download it from the saving and just
[ __ ] email 950 investors and be like
and then the title be like yo here's my
video with Gary Vee and like I mean look
I want to sell sneakers but as you know
this five minutes is not a good use of
my time for those 35 payers I did this
the same reason I do random podcasts
which is I love when people leverage me
to create their dreams beggars can't be
big yeah bro beggars can't be choosers
you want a half a million dollars you're
the only way you're gonna be able to do
it is based on somebody believing in you
you're not what are you selling you have
no data when you're an idea phase you're
selling yourself bro do you know many
people watching right now we're scared
to ask out the person that they were
most attracted to and thus missed out on
the opportunity of marrying the person
that they most were into period that's
life you don't ask you to get are we
doing another phone call no I gotta get
out of here I gotta run to something I
want to do one more Gary okay resident
one more because I feel like like this
next kid I used to like gonna be kid I
used to be on you know on the online and
I felt like if I don't answer they the
next kid I miss out on the great way
yeah so I feel like this next kid might
be special
I'm just feeling some who was the person
you were looking at on YouTube the
person right before Justin oh he was an
artist he was an author he was an artist
he was an artist that Akon had a key
members named Brooke it's Gary
Vaynerchuk you're on the askgaryvee show
with Scooter Braun hi oh my god
Brook before you do anything you need to
thanks cooter tremendously I'm about to
be late for something he pushed me
because he has that kind of energy you
need to really thanks cooter for this
moment here thank you so much
is it so my name is Brooke Johnson I'm
sorry you have applied for an internship
with your company for several several
years now since you've got the job it's
done you've got the job
SP projects you're laughing it's done
it's not I will cancel my life to make
this happen back you are an intern in
for SP it's done Brooke I'm telling you
it's done congratulations
scooter so I I drove I went to LA last
week I bought a hundred other plane
tickets just to go down there because I
was I was like hey I'm gonna get some
coffee with CEOs because no one no one
calling I live in Seattle Washington
actually Puyallup Washington you Brooke
I down to LA and I was like I'm gonna
get some coffee with CEOs because me
nobody nobody was buying on any of my
applications that are throwing in Sony
like nation did nothing and so I got a
few interviews but when I was down there
I got pickpocketed I got myself ill and
I got in a really bad car accident
I was boned and thrown into an
intersection I had the biggest interview
of my life the next day at 9:00 a.m. and
my who's around
it was adidas do both I find it NDA so I
can't tell you much it's a big big big
job and I so they interview me blah blah
but I got an email last week they're
like hey we're moving our offices so I
was like oh great I don't know to do and
I want to work in LA Brooke I have a
question for you what do you want to do
I want to change the world I understand
that broke
you're [ __ ] shopping with this
apology not ideology your [ __ ] life
into the wrong direction what kind of
job were you by I'm looking for
marketing I want to inspire people to
inspire them don't give me anymore 2019
horseshit get real practical here right
now this is the moment of your life
you're gonna watch this video every day
for the rest of your life and if you do
one more ideological [ __ ] theoretical
[ __ ] thing here when he's looking
for practicality I'm gonna punch you in
the nose okay Brooke here's my question
for you you say marketing what gives you
experience in marketing anything I have
a little bit of marketing experience I
was the president of the American
Marketing Association at my university I
successfully got a $7000 through don't
worry you're fine
I threw like I didn't sell anything I
just went to my Zumba class and it hit
these women I I got these women on board
with my my ideas and they're like yeah
well I'll give you some money and so I
walked out of the YMCA one day with
$1,000 you okay so I want to explain
what happened you Gary needs to go and
Gary we just did a call with a guy and I
just said look my whole life experience
it's always been that last one when I'm
about to leave like answer one more that
something very special happens so we
decided you were the one special I said
Gary one more so that's why he was
saying everything else so so what I'm
saying to you is I get a lot of trouble
with my staff when I meet people in the
street and they ask for an internship
and I say yes I have literally been
super pissed with me right now because I
just did it you know listen I am
actually told I'm not allowed to do that
anymore by my own company because I gave
so much trouble for giving rant and
usually they turn out to not always yeah
they're always [ __ ] they're always you
know I usually always [ __ ] but it worked
out a couple times and one time [ __ ]
nets out and guess what that's why
scooter and I have [ __ ] company's not
the [ __ ] henchmen here in the corner
okay so I'm gonna get your information
I'm breaking my rule this is not for any
kid watching him you meet me in the
street I'm not breaking my rule again
don't get it never happening
okay but what I'm gonna tell you is I
followed like the universe has fixed my
life plenty of times I was telling Gary
earlier like when I don't really know
sometimes it shows it for me you need a
break
and I think sometimes in life I was
talking to Gary Brooks start [ __ ]
crying Brooke I want explain this I was
talking I was talking to Gary about luck
earlier and what I mean by that is and I
never got to explain it I have friends
who I know are as smart as me and have
worked as hard as me and have not had
the success in life because along the
way did you think get the breaks and I
always tell them keep going the breaks
are waiting for you the breaks are
waiting for you sometimes it happens
earlier in life I got lucky it happened
earlier and sometimes it happens later
in life and sometimes it happens on the
askgaryvee show
and i think tonight happened on the
askgaryvee show so i don't know what it
will turn into but you deserve a break
so I don't I'm not giving you a job yet
but I'm gonna give you the internship
and what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pay
you minimum wage to your uncle but
unlike the other interns I'm gonna
actually make sure that like you and I
you know that I put you in a couple
projects you know to make sure that I
see what you can do on the marketing
side and that's why we did even better
it gets way better because I'm not
letting [ __ ] scooter here I'll Oprah
me so on top of that because you want to
do marketing I'm flying you I'm paying
for all this [ __ ] I'm flying you to New
York I'm putting you up in a hotel for a
week and or at a rocks house I haven't
figured it out yet and you're gonna work
here at Boehner for a week if I work
with my team for a week we're gonna give
you all the secret sauce so that when
you go back to scooters land you're not
just doing some YMCA hustle you're doing
20 19 perfect marketing you're coming
here for me we're gonna teach you as
much as we can in a week you're gonna
work 19 hours a day like our crew does
then it'll go back to scooters world and
eventually be the CMO of [ __ ] Scooter
Braun projects and Brooke copy and I'm
gonna buy you four thousand dollar car
what are you really gonna be serious she
can't get to your [ __ ] office without
a car I don't know what 4,000 gets you
in car owner you want to split it done
Brooke we're buying you 4,000 our car my
office is gonna be really pissed that
I'm just giving out cars and they've
been working with
listen they're gonna be what the [ __ ]
Brooke you I'm gonna hang up now because
I'm about to buy you a house
congratulations Brooke Brooke with my
new [ __ ] car you've got a job you
work for scooter like you're [ __ ]
coming getting [ __ ] like IP from
Boehner like shit's good tonight are you
laughing we're throwing up mild crying
awesome we love you Brooke
scooter you're amazing see yeah right
that's what we do the extra bones oh I
get it
I'm not even doing a question today that
was the [ __ ] ending of the day I love
you brother to always I'll see you soon
that was amazing see you bye
[Music]